welcome to this video playing blitz
rider from Sweden and playing a weird
line here with 92 but this is a far
better then it Leonard looks the idea is
that here I'm going to play with before
and prevent the c5 the c5 break so also
see for coming yeah it looks strange but
it has been played a number of times
already by some very strong players and
I can even mention the world champion
here Carlton his plate this 92 line and
a number of blitz games so it's not one
of those ohm ya mean big big opening
weapons that that weapon that is that is
used in serious games let's say but one
of those offbeat little lines that are
very nice to play once in a while
especially in quicker time controls ok
let's see maybe I don't know baby Bishop
a three to keep c5 under control yeah
you to get castled him need something to
drink it's also very important let's see
maybe night to be 60 it's maybe trying
to no it's not so maybe I should just
just take him and you know that's cd5 is
a bit down a bit lame
I don't really fear each five very much
but maybe queen a for the night be six
okay and okay that's not good takes
takes okay maybe maybe still gasps cd5 I
guess my t5 look strange yeah if you go
see five people still have an isolated
green pond at the end a bit I'm p.m.
somehow I think that maybe white has
still a very slight portal here I'm
somewhat quicker on those files BNC
phone I'm not sure about this decision
maybe it is good anyway because he he
needs to get to get something going here
but still okay take and now Bishop to be
too maybe at that Bishop deform or
should be to you know d 4 is not
possible i think i have night f.3d for
Bishop before Queen D force an
embarrassing little tactic one or two h5
yeah this this I don't believe really
why would you put the night on the edge
of the other rook on the edge of the
board what's this necessary I could have
gone just back to a door to e6 or
something now the book is just out of
sight him okay Bishop to where are
defying against yeah that's that's a
very stable square and now I have a real
idea and the position try to play
against this the stranded rook if he
takes you I can even take with the pawn
the rukon on h5 is the issue now you
could be one maybe I can make by the way
I can try to to trap the rook I can go
to h6 g 40 k h6 it's not a good idea ok
what I want to do is I want to exchange
the be a drug ok he may be really wants
to go to c3 and with with this night
possible ok going to activate the Queen
threaten rugae six yeah ok here i can i
can take on before and take on and play
Roxy area you see able to prevent this
and some way i don't i don't see see it
let's do it
Luke CA now wins the Queen
maybe 95 or something yeah but I have to
be sixsome Queen b6 and and winning or
not and it's enough at least maybe
that's something better but this this is
winning Queen takes rook takes saving
saving the rook and both bishop and
neither hanging yeah Brooke h5 really
was a weird move basically deciding okay
I don't need this piece anymore I put it
on age 5 mm dad if you move the Queen
i'm going to take default with the rook
saving the rook and taking the bishop
and one move
yes trying to find some sort of trick
here I don't believe there is this one
and is playing without the whole rook on
age five this is still connected we can
check that he was connected okay I can't
take root before now right there is no
drawback to that ok mmmm can i play with
this I can't play Queen B seven anyway
with the rook c8 coming I can also just
retreat your Oakley I mean it's really
just an extra look
time warning
yeah he's continuing
rook h2 this rook takes f8 check greene
takes our take the rook and King takes i
have this sat night at five winning the
Queen next and check the chick made
maybe but let's just take the Queen
check check check and Queen g3 mate
checkmate yeah this was all due to Luke
age five I think if he goes just back
maybe e6 i don't know but i probably
would have just played rook e8 back
makes the most sense I guess then what
is going here and this is hmm very very
slightly better for Wyatt he's got d5 as
a weakness and a5 is also bid weaker
than a two and so just a bit exposed but
it's very little maybe for a very good
technical player and this is this is
very very nice but I think it's a slight
edge for white it's nothing too serious
and after Luke h5 I think black is in
big trouble I mean he is really playing
without this piece so he could have
played a ledbetter for sure but oh yeah
I was this is the blunder I i forgot
about night i forgot about the capture
ah this this would have been very
embarrassing them they can take here and
here and then play 93 I totally
overlooked that yeah why does the number
of good term good options probably some
things that something easiest is this
van rook see one or
maybe I'm Brooke c6 this kind of moves
yeah but this this now was I can also
take on be 407 now this also seemed fine
to hear well here this is just just
winning he could he could have taken
here and take in here I still thought
that would be very nice for Wyatt but
the computer is not agreeing at all I
seem okay I wanted to take with the pawn
actually as this is maybe Queen h4 I
don't know so I wanted to take care but
now the computer points of this move and
this is strong the idea is to at the
right moment sacrifice him for example
if we consider this he can jam something
like that and this is wrong check yeah I
didn't really refute it I didn't really
refute rook h5 convincingly especially
will pinpoint is a big problem big lemon
yeah I should probably take and just
keep the big advantage okay thanks for
watching